[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the true Geordie podcast
today's guest was one of the original
guests that we had one of the most
special guests Nick Yaris welcome back
bro thank you Brian it's an honor to be
back man it's it's so cool to see you
come up to me on the street you know I I
saw you last time we we were in a studio
and I saw you walking up to me and I was
like there's my boy yeah yeah we've kept
in touch and
um you know you are such a special guest
a very Unforgettable I'm sure that the
uh the original fans would love to see
you back here but obviously we've got
new new people who might not be aware of
your story
so just to give some context of what you
are most known for
um I'll let you say it because no one
says it better than you thank you
my name is Nick Yaris I'm from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania for those of
you don't know my story yet I was
convicted of the rape and murder of a
woman I never met at the age of 20
having received the three-day murder
trial I then spent the next 23 years in
solitary confinement except for a brief
lapse when I escaped from Death Row in
1985 spent 25 days on the FBI's 10 most
wanted list until I had the courage to
turn myself back in
I was then returned to Pennsylvania
where I was originally sentenced to die
and I became the first man in the United
States to seek DNA testing to prove my
innocence it took me 15 years and a
letter to the courts asking to die to
get that accomplished
in 2004 in January I was released
in the 19 years that it preceded that
I've gone around the world teaching
people about neuroplasticity healing
I had the great honor of being in
England at the time when I first met
Brian
to show
courage and ability
I came on his first podcast
after losing
our daughter to Sid's
Brian thought I would be distraught and
anyone could appreciate that I would be
but it was so important for this man and
I to bring a cogent message to his
listeners
and that podcast was huge because there
were so many Lads that reached out to me
and told me how much I meant to them and
loved me instantly for pouring my heart
out I was one of the greatest gifts
Brian because I needed that
reinvigoration of love because of what I
was going through personally
I mean
you know because you're a death row
prisoner on the internet there's always
going to be the Sinister aspect and of
course I was inundated with the attacks
that I might have killed the child and
all those things so imagine that I've
not only endured the sufferings of
having been a falsely accused of killing
a woman and raping her and being put on
death row
but I would also be accused later in
Freedom of killing a child and you can
imagine how psychologically that could
affect you but I was given the grace of
having been falsely accused of something
previously and it it gave me a shield
because you know if someone says
something dirty about you and you know
it's not true instantly you're strong
do you know what I mean like no no no no
that ain't me and from that becomes a
determination of Who You Are
now
I left England in 2013 to develop a
major motion picture about my life
I came back in
2016. was that was that the fear of 13
documentary or was that something else
oh no the fear of document fear of 13
came out in 2015. okay I was with this
girl Jesse and she left it was crazy so
right before the film came out too
so I was um getting all these amazing
messages
Random House Publishers wanted to
republish my book seven days to live
under the title fear of 13 count down to
execution I wrote a stage play based on
the two black gentlemen from the movie
Fear of 13 Wesleyan Butch a beautiful
musical called Big House voices and I
was having that developed and I met an
English woman named Laura and I fell in
love and I was living in the west
country
so everything was back to good you know
what I mean look not who you're with
when I met you exactly yeah Laura so
look at that see who you've got all the
children with no so um my only daughter
is with another woman that I married in
2005 when I first moved here I came here
to speak before Parliament ironically
about mental health issues in the
prisons and wrongful convictions and
also an embargo against Pennsylvania for
having the death penalty
so that's when I first moved here I had
a child from that first relationship and
then when I met Laura I was in
Basingstoke and I met this girl who just
blew me away you know what I mean I
remember the Zenith of my happiness at
that time was having the honor and
distinction of going to Geneva at the
request of the president of the EU to
address the United Nations Human Rights
Council and to have me and Laura in such
a beautiful atmosphere like that walking
around Lake Geneva it was one of the
best nights of my life right
I go then to I met people from the
Muhammad Ali Foundation
and one of my best friends Anthony
samandani is an iranian-born American
who is next level
so he and a director named Alejandra
monteverdi and some very big celebrities
I just told you about are launching a
brand new major motion picture about my
life
and I have the honor and distinction
today to be launching
ourhealing.org a universal un-sponsored
platform I'm going to be the spokesman
of
to help people not commit suicide to
deal with mental health issues and since
March is mental health awareness it's a
great month to launch This Global
program to get people not to kill
themselves
now
you and I did your podcast in 2016
remember yeah
and then you messaged Joe Rogan on his
birthday which is Jamie Lee's birthday
the little baby that died in our home
and then I commented on that
and and this is how I ended up on the
Joe Rogan podcast because of you oh
that's so funny and the crazy thing is
when I went to do his podcast you know
how my life is this last week it was
just like that Brian I got suckered by a
guy who was trying to get a education
program launched from New Zealand to go
meet Stedman Graham the night before I
went to Joe Rogan's podcast Steadman
Graham is Oprah Winfrey's husband
so I go in this big event after being
told Steadman told his personal
assistant all these gracious things
about me so I'm like wow the biggest boy
in social platform I mean this guy
builds everything right
I go to the event and I introduce myself
he has no clue who I am
Brian they have this big introduction
where everybody gets three minutes to
tell the room who they are you know they
stopped when I spoke I shut it all down
right yeah yeah and then I walked out
I told him this I said look I'm very
sorry I'm not anyone of a business
acumen I don't understand how to build
these platforms I was brought here under
the circumstances that you sir knew who
I was
now that I'm aware that I was
duplicitously brought here
I have to go and I walked out man and
then I got back in the car with this
dude didn't say a word to him 80 miles
an hour back to Burbank to go to stay in
a hotel and then the next morning I had
like four meetings and then I went on
Rogan okay let me let me check here
because
I understand that you have CTE with from
brain trauma from for one thing that you
didn't mention was that you are and
you're a child you suffered a lot of
abuse and then in prison you suffered
abuse and we're also talking about
post-traumatic stress disorder so as
you've admitted to me you know
emotionally sometimes
uh you know that takes over it does and
so for you who have felt so let down
that night by that person who led you on
it explains a little bit because when
you went on Joe Rogue I was a mess yeah
I was texting Laura that we she was up
in Oregon we're doing the daggers by
text by Doug as you mean arguing yeah
yeah because she was up there opening up
a shop with her friend she didn't like
the fact that I was on the road without
her like the all the normal things a
couple can go through okay so me and her
in Discord I just got played for a nut
by a dude that was just so desperate to
get money for his program he lied to me
to bring me to meet Stedman Graham and I
had to be honest with Steadman and walk
out because it's not fair to me to sit
there and be used all night and then
have this guy Shine off of my being used
so then you go on Rogan and and I
remember watching Rogan thinking this is
going to be perfect yeah because you've
got a great speaker you've got Joe Rogan
there but you
um you basically went to bits and and I
got attacked you could say Joe Rogan
couldn't Joe
um
his specialty isn't like necessarily the
most emotional podcasts it's more of the
informative podcast that's kind of what
I would say he does and he didn't really
I think understand the full picture of
what you'd been through in your life
um and the and the comments were really
bad people were calling you a liar
people were saying a lot of the and I
felt so bad for you because I was like
people don't understand like they're
judging you through the eye of who they
are in their lives they don't understand
that like you're you're a kid who's been
through so much and it clearly you
weren't in a good way so do you want to
explain a little bit about what it was
like to go through that as well
yeah so
honestly the very first message I got
after doing Rogan
was from The Following
hello Mr Yaris I am a disabled Native
American combat vet who lost both legs
in war
thank you for going on Joe Rogan today I
think I can make it
Dear Mr Yaris I'm a 27 year old man who
had open heart surgery at the age of 17
I got addicted to drugs because of pain
medications were withdrawn
I've now been on the street for 10 years
and my parents don't speak to me but I
just got off the phone with my mom so
Brian
I know that there was a lot of attacks
like you said because people couldn't
grasp what I was going through
but I still got through to people so I
have to always understand a lot of
people aren't going to like me a lot of
people won't accept me and I have to
continue on doing things despite that
recently I just went through a lot more
trauma but and you know this look
it's crazy I'm walking around in England
right now with no identification because
my passport was maliciously reported as
stolen
so I gotta get a new passport but
nothing will stop me like I keep going
through all these things where
it does feel like the issues that you
have post leaving Death Row I followed
you it's not like you've just
slip right back into society and and
people expect that of you but that's a
how could you I know so I want to clear
up one thing I've been attacked for so
much everyone keeps saying I got four
million dollars that's a lie um I'm
talking about the compensation that
people think you've got from being right
it's so unjustly incarcerated I had to
go out and hire a lawyer the lawyer took
1.3 million dollars off the top I was
living in England when I got the
settlement at 1.9 to The Exchange I got
1.3 million pounds and I had to give my
wife half of it because I was separating
and leaving her and she said that the UK
courts were going to give it to her in
divorce anyway
so I I ended up with six hundred
thousand pounds I built I bought a house
in St Leonard's and I started oh is that
the countryside house that I've seen you
in in America or is that the difference
no I was down in St Leonards on sea and
I had a house down there and I was and I
had I did it for a reason I knew that
there was going to be the last summer I
would have custody or control of being
in my daughter Laura's life so I why did
you know that because my ex-wife had
gotten a new partner
and after she had gotten a new partner I
knew her machinations would be move Nick
out of the way so her and her new Nick
could have a life together with my
daughter
she did exactly that
she used the machinations of the court
system by getting me to send her a
stupid email by provoking me to get a
restraining order to consecutive years
in a row and then I didn't see Laura
because the court awarded full custody
to my ex and then in the end I was
allowed to see her for like 15 minutes
in a McDonald's if I bought presents for
her so I went through that thing where I
lost the child and I was living in Saint
Leonard's and my brother Mike was doing
poorly so I flew to Las Vegas with him
and I had an amazing time with my big
brother we rented a car I got him a
hooker got him all clean oh yeah you
know come on man I I won ten thousand
dollars at Blackjack he had this dream
of going to Mick Jagger's house my
brother fell off of a roof at the age of
17 had open cranial surgery and lost his
personality
he became alcoholic this is my father's
been through hell my little brother died
in the basement while I was on death row
okay so yeah we're gonna have to
backtrack here because I can only
imagine how the audience has listened so
but I just wanted to finish that okay
2010 I took my brother to Bakersfield
California to buy a property called
Saddle Mountain and we were going to
raise horses together because I could
get him off the street because he was an
alcoholic
and I met a girl and my father said
Nikki I want you to stay in England for
Laura I got Mikey
and then less than a year later he died
in his sleep from a seizure heart attack
right okay and when you say that you had
a younger brother you had a brother that
died as well when you were young in 2002
my little brother Marty died of
Oxycontin alcohol combination overdose
from my parents basement my father
walked downstairs and he was dead
everything that's been done to me has
given me a chance to get through to
people in a way that I could have never
had a gift
literally since Joe Rogan I've saved 7
000 people from killing themselves how
would you come up with that number
because I have it recorded with other
people I'm working with others this is
great I always keep those messages there
I'll show you the DMS and stuff in your
yeah yeah I'm gonna start sending you
messages from your audience this is
where some dude's going to tell me to
tell you today we saved him from killing
himself or killing someone else or
getting smashed on drugs well I've
definitely had my ups and downs in life
with the Suicidal Thoughts I've been on
antidepressants I'm currently on
antidepressants and uh you know thank
God that they have medication and help
out there and and people like yourself
who are speaking the way you are well
see this is why I think that you're the
perfect example of understanding and
using my techniques
brine the way to heal yourself is to
re-white right your brain like you did
with your body in a gym okay
neuroplasticity is a concentrated effort
to detoxify the PTSD from your brain and
how you do it is utter politeness
listening to music and prayer
interacting in nature or with children
these things are real I go out of my
door every day trying to be exceedingly
polite because Robin Sharma the foremost
authority on neuroplasticity taught me
that what I'm doing is I'm creating a
reward system for my brain it
matter about the response of the person
that I'm being polite to my brain is
seeking this interaction that gives me a
reward system now this is the
development of charm and Charisma I can
walk into a room and I can blow people
away because over the last 19 years I've
been practicing kindness as a strength
enabling eraser of all of my PTSD
as I sit here before you I've never had
one psychiatric counseling session I've
never had to take medications to give me
my balance back I've learned a tool that
works yo you you have had issues where
you like you explain you're you're
having difficulty with a relationship or
you're having difficulty without how do
you cope in those moments where you
let's let's take for example you've been
removed from your daughter's life is
that still the case yes okay how do you
cope with that
all right
I've learned
to be kind to myself
it's the hardest thing for most men
we're quick to say we're a piece of [__]
we hate ourselves those [__] words
have power man all right so if those
words have power
Nick you can do this go out and try to
be a loving father to whoever will allow
that to replace what's been taken Brian
is all you you kind of adopted your
partners children yeah yeah that's why I
went I was so eager to be a dad again
because it's my dream in the film the
documentary the fear of 13 my last
quotes were I was going to find a girl I
was going to fall in love and best of
all I was going to be a great dad
I wanted to have that feeling and
Bethany and Zara are two brilliant girls
and I had the distinction and honor of
being in her lives from the ages of two
and four where I basically lost Laura so
God gave me two for one he took
I really believe so much in my
spirituality I look at it this way
who am I to question God and cry
one of the hardest things that you went
through was obviously losing your baby
um and that happened right where
we'd met I didn't want to pry I didn't
want to push because it was very raw
very fresh and I wanted to concentrate
on the bulk of the story before that
um and to be honest I was scared to push
the wrong button because I thought I
can't imagine anything worse than what
you were going through now you're
looking back at that with the current
state of mind that you're in how do you
how do you feel about going through
something so
yeah
first and foremost you have to think of
others in times of Terror
if you don't you're going to just
implode
I have a built-in factor of being a true
empath
I have empathy for others
that allows me to step back
for those of never anyone who's never
heard this story
my wife and I were living out in
Ilchester area
and Laura my partner
had a flu called you know it was going
around the house
and she's a busybody she has to have a
neat house you know the girl you know
what I mean
so I was like Laura come on I want you
to just go ahead and have a lay down
with us
I put the baby in the crib upstairs in
the bedroom I came back downstairs I
grabbed Laura by the waist threw her on
the sofa and we're having a nap
20 minutes later I go upstairs to check
on the baby she's dead
and this is the the worst moment of my
life
I picked the baby up I'm screaming
I'm in Terror
I go down the stairs large just loses it
our lovely neighbor runs in and starts
this piece CPR as I'm on the phone
trying to get the services to help
in the aftermath of something this
[__] big you don't do that thing
where it's you
I had to think of the mother I watched
go through his cesarean and nearly die
the reason Laura survived surgery is we
kissed
you know before she went into operating
theater we kissed for a solid 10 minutes
and I lowered her blood rate the doctors
in the or said that I was the best thing
possible because all the while I had her
connected to me mentally so that when
her blood rate dropped down so low she
passed out when she came back in she saw
me
you don't make this about you in that
moment Brian I had the man up for these
children and for this woman and
she just reminded me of this when I was
struggling just a couple of nights ago
with these PTSD dreams I don't have it
in my day
she said
you told me to eat you told me to care
for myself and you made me listen to you
now I'm telling you this isn't going to
be real when you wake up I'll be here
for you I love you but listen to me eat
sleep rest breathe
see
so anybody who's gone through the loss
of a family member and a tragedy
try and think about all of the other
people around you
and how your strength can save them from
additional suffering
be that
brilliant English Irish whales lad and
take that next level of pain and
suffering and spare mom dad and everyone
else from seeing you capitulate to your
anger
and that will make their suffering
better
I think that's a great thing to say to
me because I know uh I think we're
heading in it as a generation now the
people who I know and have been around
in the last few years a lot of people
just focus on themselves they're not
trying to help the next guy or the other
family members and one thing that you
touched on there which I find
interesting I have PTSD dreams night
terrors some people call them things of
that nature and it's really been a
problem in my life where I've struggled
to sleep and that's when you turn to
other things to help you sleep and
before you know it you know things are
difficult in your life
um so yeah what are those like for you I
can't pick the baby up
oh my arms won't work and I I go after
this last incident last month with
another death in my life that you know
about that I don't want to repeat
because the children don't know this and
Laura has asked me to protect them
it's just such a near exact thing where
I'll end up screaming right and I was
helpless to change the situation that my
dreams got really wicked lately
um two nights ago
I literally
got up it in the middle of the night
ready to fight
it's the fear flight thing in your brain
yeah right so I'm gonna have to start
teaching you a very brilliant breathing
exercise that will put you down better
than dopamine all right so you do know
that your sleep is regulated from your
stomach
your stomach has to release dopamine for
you to pass out if you have an upset
stomach or you're going through
internalizations the stomach acid Rises
so much it won't let the dopamine come
out so when we're stressed out that's
why we struggle to sleep so I after this
program I'm going to teach you how to
fix that while lying on your back so you
actually get high and pass out
well you know this stream specifically
you said the helplessness and the fight
or flight those are two things that are
consistent in my dreams and I think
that's because of my PTSD
um I I'm in situations where I'm trying
to save people yeah and I can't move or
stuff like that right and this is
exactly what mine is I can't pick the
baby up yeah I've run into the room I'm
screaming in the horror and I can't do
anything my arms won't work that's crazy
how did you and Laura like cope because
I know you Laura have had time apart
since that point was was that one of the
reasons no so covet wiped us out you
know I was on my way to the Royal
Copenhagen theater the ballet theater in
and I was on my way to the London School
of film where the movie Fear of 13 was
made to speak
gone everything and then we had an 81
year old alcoholic landlord who used to
come to the house with a pistol
demanding money
and I'm like I gotta kill this old dude
or he's going to kill me in front of the
bad thing Brian is the children's window
will be right there
and one day he came up they're all drunk
so you guys are struggling to make ends
meet and he's covered yeah and he came
up to the house Nick I want to see you
where's my money I said look you need to
stop coming to my house
like it's something you can do as a
landlord and don't come here with a
pistol on your hip like you're trying to
intimidate me
and I look and there's Zara right at the
window man I'm thinking if this dude
kicks off I gotta break his jaw and take
the gun off the more he's going he's
going to cap me you know what I mean so
me and Laura said no we're not doing
this to the children and we moved into a
tent on the chetco bar river right above
Brookings Oregon and we lived in the
woods for the next two years I remember
seeing you
do this and from afar I was really
worried about you yeah because there was
Gunners they me and the kids was in the
car people shot at the car we had a bear
attack at the camp
uh the dude Sam that we were living with
fired a 45 pistol at a cougar that was
jumping out of the woods so it's real I
felt really bad for you and on the
family like you know how does it as men
we want to provide we want to take care
of our people and you're now in the
woods and like living off the land
pretty much like how how did that feel
humiliating I lost everything I couldn't
take care of these kids and my wife she
had to go work in town cleaning houses
well I put the kids online and did their
schooling we used to have to climb up on
a second Ridge and we called it habib's
internet cafe so that we had a place up
there on a big rock that would get
signal for the children to go online and
then I would walk back down with the
dogs protecting us
I've been through every extreme in
America and it's crazy like um
it's wild wild west boy it really is man
and am I right and thinking you so she
went back to England yeah so did you
separate or yeah so I had to I got a
[__] conviction and and America and
kept me go back there so yeah what was
that uh I got befriended by a wealthy
Patron who wanted to buy books for the
Dr Phil show when I got my friend off of
death row and tried to give me access
and and tried to Splash the cast on us
in the hopes of luring me away from
Laura and then didn't get her way and
spitefulness oh a woman so I got
convicted of theft
and I just finished two years probation
this is all true I don't I don't mind I
didn't do it you know what I mean so in
the end yes is there a conviction there
then yeah yeah so there you go I
couldn't come back to the United Kingdom
and be with my wife for two years I had
to wait all this out in the woods with
nothing for the last what did they say
you stole
credit card money for using to purchase
my books right for the Dr Phil show that
I never appeared on because Cove had
canceled it
me and a guy named Jason floam went to
Los Angeles because I did the
extraordinary thing of keeping my word
to a guy named Walter oh God and I got
him off of death row after 20 years of
trying for him
death row and I got two guys life
sentences so six together I saved can we
go back to this this charge that you got
because I'm I'm so confused all right
it's it's a mentally ill person who is
still at this point trying to hurt me is
that why you said you had a restraining
order put on someone no that's that's
here in England so I know I was on the
phone all night I know I was on the
phone all night swearing out a statement
because of the current stalking
situation in my life that's gone on for
12 years all right a lot of the attacks
on the internet were orchestrated by my
ex-partner who has gone out and
solicited mentally ill people and
energized them what lies about me so
that she can get them to attack me
that's why I have so much dispirchment
on my character okay so this was a
partner who you were once with and
you're saying that she's telling people
stuff about you to get them to attack
you right like she goes um recently
she got a hold of people from my
GoFundMe anybody that donated gets a
message from her she's seriously
stalking me she got one woman
in England here who I was speaking to
that on the day that I just told you
about experience another death I told
her about that incident but wasn't
telling Laura or anybody else because I
didn't want the children of Laura to be
hurt by that information
my ex-partner got that voicemail message
and sent it to lard just Crush her
you see what I mean okay so where does
this stem from where was the original
path out pathologically distorted need
for vengeance because
for leaving her right okay this is the
mother of my first child right okay all
right and what is she accusing you of to
these people who are donating or
anything she can so basically
she has an intention of making me look
as dirty and as silicious as she can in
Vengeance to destroy me first this is
going on I had to quit Twitter 15 000
followers I had to give up Facebook 25
000 followers because I was being
inundated by people that she went out
and recruited
it got so bad Laura would go through so
much trauma
Karen constantly would message Laura
like I haven't been with this woman in
almost 17 years and she every partner
since then she's been involved with
right so imagine no matter what trauma
I'm going through in life that we talked
about I got a stalker for the last 12
years who has a partner that's so gross
he was on Facebook
saying how he was going to have a
daddy-daughter day with my child Laura
Rebecca Yaris
taunting me man alongside my ex and what
was the recent issue because you
messaged me something about uh yeah they
canceled my passport they uh Karen got
in touch with this woman here
that got the message about the death and
sent it to Laura
and also had an image of my passport
because this woman had tricked me into
saying she was going to get me a flight
here and I would pay her back
and they canceled my passport
so I they did everything possible to
sabotage me from being here today with
you
I got Aphasia from having my head bashed
in and being raped as a seven-year-old
boy
so I had Aphasia all my life and then
last year I flipped my car over and both
dogs shot out of the window the front
window and I survived but I took a
concussion because I kept telling my boy
I have a friend named Jason Daley okay
okay and I was telling him I don't
remember hanging upside down so
the one of the things that I found with
you when you talk is we're all over the
place I'm going to try and keep this in
in a line for people around us yeah yeah
so I remember this happening this car
accident and I remember your car being
you sent a picture or you put a poster
picture on Instagram of your car
and it it was bashed up it was bad and I
think the comment was something along
the lines of we lost everything now yeah
so you were really low and how how did
you flip the car what happened there so
I was working on an equestrian property
that had handicapped children on it and
my job was to take care of the horses so
that these kids said that would
otherwise thrash and have all these
problems could sit calmly with the horse
so it was brilliant I did all this
concrete work I laid over three thousand
pounds of concrete by myself building
you see them pictures I was ripped right
because I was doing concrete work all
that day and it was so cold that it
never got below uh freezing and it was
sunny but I went down a mountain road to
go into town to get dog food and food
for myself there was a patch of black
ice
I was only going 35 miles an hour when I
hit a corner I spun around twice I hit
the burn and then I flipped I saw the
dogs go out the window I flipped again
and then I don't remember all I remember
was standing there going come here mango
come here baby she was on the road right
by me whimpering and blue ran off for
the next two hours the crazy thing is my
phone was trapped under the car I heard
whimper and I tried to pick the car up
and then I found my phone under the car
and the ice and it was stuck to
Instagram that's how it ended up with a
live post
I couldn't get not and I was like
William my friend in cave junks I'm like
William you got to come help me please
and this dude comes out of nowhere and
his his is is the lights on the road
that lit up that car
um and he couldn't believe I lived
everybody else was like how did you
survive my boy Jason that night he was
talking to me in the RV and he said Nick
why aren't you freaking out man I said
honestly Jason
the first time I almost got killed I
freaked out probably the third time I
almost got killed but this is like
number 11 man and it don't freak you out
no more
and if it wasn't for the fact that
you've been messaging me every single
time that these things happen I'd be
sitting here right now and it does feel
like a hell of a lot of things and a
hell of a lot of different like you know
what you've been telling me as these
things I told you all along yeah and
what is your current status in your
brain health
so I developed
um Aphasia from blunt force trauma at
the age of seven
Aphasia can be recognized as simply as
someone stuttering their brain is not
able to slow down to let their veracular
take over and speak
in times of stress I become monocited
and I have to shut down my brain won't
let me see out of the left eye
CTE is a brain
diagnosis for NFL football players this
is why a lot of them kill themselves
I'll kill other people as well yeah yeah
and they struggle to regulate their
emotions no no it's anger all right so
if you think about it there's a
poisonous side that tells me
I have to end this this is crazy Brian
like I can't keep suffering like this
you have to instead of a normal person
saying Nate I need a break from this I
need to pack away I'm diving in because
the CT is driving me it's hard though
isn't it because I know a lot of people
who aren't nice to themselves who don't
they don't get it well it's very
difficult isn't it it's a lot easier to
criticize yourself and tell yourself
well you're not the best version of
yourself and how you could always be
better it's all what happened to me
where that was some wrong [__] and I'm
gonna try and work through it or I'm
better than that
you see what I mean it's very hard to
take the high road all the time but I do
try all right so even if you don't take
the high road and you fall prey what do
you do Brian you come back to yourself
because you have to live with yourself
and at some point you're gonna have to
forgive yourself and that's what's
killing you well you know what that's
why I try and always
give myself the least amount of regrets
possible so even when people treat me
like [__] I always try and say
I'm going to give the best I can give
and then at the cutoff point where as
you once said to me I dismiss them in my
life
but up until that point you you give an
olive branch you give an olive branch
until they keep breaking off every
single Olive Branch that you have left
right and then you can walk away from a
situation feeling I did everything I
could and then you're not going to be as
critical as yourself all right even if
you don't get that chance and you blow
it what happens when you [__] up right
no no like that's the good part but in
your your personal life you've grown it
and you know it and then what do you do
you started the cycle you internalized
you beat yourself down probably got high
over it and then no seriously dick this
is the usual thing I've watched this oh
yeah and then we come back and we set
ourselves up to do it again I personally
have these two
sides to me where I'm the most critical
of myself of anyone like I got you know
we all get things on the internet said
about us no one's more critical of me
than me I beat myself up a lot but then
also I have this like
but enough's enough and now I'm gonna be
show them who I really are maybe how do
you maybe you need to hear between those
two or no no so it's weird I had the
blessing of having been called a sick
psychological rapist stalking murderer
nothing can hurt so once every yeah once
you've had the worst under you you're
bulletproof right so I'm bulletproof
because of that and the night that I sat
down and asked to dismiss my appeals
nothing can bother me I I always go back
to the worst night and say this ain't it
I've had the worst night of my night
this ain't it I can come back okay
the other point that I wanted to make to
you Brian and I think maybe you need to
hear this
I couldn't have made this without you
and I can't let you do that to yourself
you you taught me at a time of tyranny
and loss
that I needed to be strong right and
then secretly nobody noticed you were
the only person I ever did any of these
kind of things with that stayed my
friend hmm you need to go and put
perspective on who you are today from
where you were that's a hard thing to do
right no it's easy because you know now
you're a lot stronger because you were
there
I do feel the way you're speaking but I
I but it's those moments though it's not
it's it's I go to them too Brian I get
knocked down so you're gonna get knocked
the [__] down so what how many times
you've been popped in the head no it's
it's not that it's not the knockdowns of
life it's it's what I say to myself in
those dark moments that that is the
challenge here okay and that when you
know when you're like well then you need
it's like 10 o'clock 11 o'clock at night
and it's dark out and you know you're
sort of mulling things over and you're
critiquing how your life has turned out
and you know and you're looking at what
you've put into life and you're looking
at what life is and you're asking
yourself the question of how the [__] is
it here how the [__] is this you know
and don't get me wrong I'm grateful for
what I do have but when I look at what
I've what I've been through
um
you know you mentioned Karma I've I find
it hard to believe in karma when I know
how good I've been to people how good I
how nice I am inside and the way I've
been treated it's difficult to to make
peace with that you know okay but maybe
the last person I had your and your
energy [__] a lot of [__] up and
you're paying for that
100 so if you're paying for it why are
you questioning God's toll gate
I don't know if I'm uh yeah yeah I hear
what you're saying this is I see this is
the point we pick out a point where our
ego makes us then decide
and that's where you're going with this
you're look what you're you're actually
torment yourself over your own kindness
that's not fair Brian look in in the
scope of it yeah you're internalizing
about relationship difficulties
situational difficulty where you were
trying to be good good that's not fair
that's like me criticizing you for
trying to be [__] nice that's not
fair on you you're not able to love
yourself enough yet to be kind to
yourself
and this is the point that will change
everything about why you're going
through the PTSD overriding it with
neuroplasticity healing will change
everything about your life because every
time you go out on that street you got a
chance to heal your brain
I saw this really remarkable thing once
that proved my point I as a 21 year old
man
was being sentenced to death when the
courthouse got struck by a boulder
lightning man
[__] it up knocked the power out of the
building they took me upstairs and they
put me in this room and I'm watching
over a courtyard and there I'm watching
Humanity before me
some people looked up at me and jeered
and gave me the dirty looks but I heard
this voice
it said
look him in the eye
I didn't see nobody
when I went down and I I was pronounced
to be put to death
I asked his honor why he couldn't look
me in the eye while he was sentencing me
to death as if he was ashamed
he lifted his head and said do you have
anything else to say
I said yeah you can go to hell that's
all they put in the newspaper baby you
get it all right yeah they left but I
did what God told me no one could look
me in the eye while they were sentenced
me to death I was so insulted that no
one could look me in the eye while they
were taking my life I demanded that
it's it's hard when a group of people
are saying that you're something that
you're not and I don't know how on Earth
you
manage to be okay with life after that
because I had a harder Journey where
when I got thrown in prison they beat me
and I wasn't allowed to speak for my
first two years in that cell man I got
my ass whooped on my 22nd birthday for
singing happy birthday man
so they rush in with the shields on and
the big gear and then they got a nurse
she's got a ride she got a a stad vest
on and a riot helmet on and she's got a
a needle full of Thorazine in her arm as
soon as they get you on the ground she
runs in the middle and Jabs you in the
ass with it and plunges it and then
you're gone for a week man
so that was Huntington State Prison the
only prison in America ever condemned
for its active practices of torture
yeah I remember you mentioning something
about how these prison guards would make
you guys fighting Yeah man so all right
imagine that you have one million
prisoners become 2 million prisoners
overnight and you have large numbers of
black prisoners getting their ass
whooped in the middle of the mountains
by white guards but now black officers
were brought up from the city and
they're witnessing it oh
oh no
it wasn't open season anymore right so
in this weird way on the back of death
row in b-blog the guards came up with
this cockamami scheme to have Gladiator
day man so as soon as the lead tenant
wasn't working on a Sunday it's open
season
so my first encounter was a dude bigger
than you man
and I had to dislocate his his ankle and
smash his face in my elbow because I
promised my mom I'm going home so no
matter how many cage fights I had and no
one connected a bounty on me did it
I got some crazy thing where I just I
had this super Fierce ability to defend
myself you know what I mean you're
strong as well I can see that so dude
yeah not only that I learned all the
defense manuals one of the first Gracies
ever incarcerated was on my block he
taught me MMA so yeah like it's crazy
how many different techniques and styles
I can make a weapon out of a pair of
underwear in a magazine and kill you and
never leave my cell man that's the level
of prison I was on you know the worst of
the worst yeah so I've been groded
stabbed
I've been shaved shanked I know the
difference between both uh yeah I had a
lot of things done to me and the guards
in the aftermath that of riot
I got spared the first day but about a
month about a month after the 1989 Riot
I was knocked unconscious and I lost a
few days of my life from having a
serious beaten and then a year after I
returned to prison from turning myself
in from escaping from Death Row they
beat me for four minutes and paraded me
around on a riot Stick Dude I watched a
a CCTV clip the other day of a prison in
America yeah they killed that boy yeah
you see that one where there's like five
of them and they just that's what they
did to me dude I told you that they made
sure this boy was dead it was it was
horrendous during the riot Brian do you
know what happens after a riot in
America they bring
the National Garden these ain't guards
so
by they set the buildings on fire I was
in an old prison that was built in the
1800s for mentally ill men
like there was writing on my floor from
1904 you know so
the National Guard came in and took
Recon control of the prison and they
drug everybody past my cell because I
was on the bottom tier by the exercises
cages that they stacked the bodies up
like cords of wood man
they beat prisoners of death and
everything yeah and what what shocked me
when I was watching this kind of footage
and you know I've seen some
documentaries about this stuff is how
quickly these people get killed by these
other prisoners I mean it is I didn't
ever have a chance to square up in the
queensbury's rule it's not like that no
no these guys have got weapons yeah so I
I had I also had a bounty on me early on
so anybody that killed me got 10 grand
so a lot of dudes try to collect you
mean about on you from from how from who
from people wanting to see the rapist
murder of Mrs Craig dying so in in
America you could reach out man if you
got a little bit of coin if dudes in the
county jail know that they're going to
get money on their account for taking
you out that's why a lot of those
attacks happen and they've got nothing
to lose right no the first dude that
attacked me had 36 years in and he
stabbed me in a chest in holmesburg
prison and if it wasn't for a dude named
Michael Wolff hitting him with a bench
I'd be dead
hmm so that's where they made
um law-abiding citizen I've been oh I
just went back there and made that new
documentary and I'm in that prison
where I got stabbed what was it like
being back there
I had to touch the walls make sure it
was real really yeah man what the felt
we had to be able to walk out of there
and now you're free man after putting
yourself back in there what's weird is
I was it I was back in a prison
especially one where I was almost
murdered
and it was cool that I wasn't there
that that kid that or whatever he was
there
but I'd never been there as this you
know I mean this man you know this grown
person felt like a different person yeah
that's fascinating isn't it
it's not weird how we differentiate Eros
of our lives like different people yep
you've just came back to England I'm so
in love with England because imagine you
could offered death row and you can go
somewhere speak your own language and
the people
aren't the ones that hurt you
the the that makes perfect sense yeah
and everything was brand new for me I
was so childlike I still remember the
first time I saw the Moon
I was so excited to see my first full
moon I grabbed a big bowl of ice cream
and a blanket and I threw open the
windows in this bedroom and I sat there
in amazement that I could finally see
the moon after so many years in solitary
confinement
it was that kind of Glee and joy I knew
I would lose over years but I was
desperately clinging onto it at first of
all I mean I interviewed a lot of people
over this last seven years or whatever
since I last seen you but of all the
people you definitely are up there with
how much you consider
everything in life let me put you in
your bathroom for 23 years and see what
you do about consideration oh yeah
that's what it was like Brian yeah eight
thousand fifty seven days 23 hours a day
or more
and what do you think the closest you
came
to harm in yourself was do you have a
memory that's yeah my first birthday as
a free person really my family didn't
want to celebrate my birthday because my
father's favorite niece is born a day
before me and she was turning 21 that
year she's the little girl I kiss when I
escaped from Death Row man that's crazy
so
um they decided to have this big blowout
21st birthday for my niece but they
didn't want to combine my birthday with
it
it would overshadow her you know what I
mean and was that bothering you oh it
drove me [__] nuts man well he's up
because I waited 21 years to have a a
birthday cake
um
it really ate at me you know so
I was riding this motorcycle and I saw
like a lorry coming up on the road I was
so Furious I said [__] it just
go ahead and then I skid it to a stop
it's crazy
it was on uh Route 55 over in New Jersey
Swedesboro
skid to a stop on this bike after doing
90.
and I look right across the road there
it's an old man walking with his dog you
know and I said [__] I ain't never gonna
get to be an old man like that walking
my dog am I
well if that's the case I ain't killing
myself then [__] I'm gonna ride it
out as long as I can
it's interesting though to see the way
you mentioned that birthday
I could see the the feeling was still
there yeah it was yeah
you asked me how close I was going to go
into that truck
but it's terrible how you can have that
feeling
and then
it was 19 years ago I wasted that moment
because the trade-off is I lived 19
years on my dream when I got out I said
man
when I got my health back I said man if
I can live 23 years of Freedom I'll
forgive everyone
but man I've forgiven everyone already
because it ain't about that
you know the best humor you can have in
the world is Gallows humor yeah oh my
God I got some funny stories for you man
death row is the [__] you know what I
mean I had my the first guy that really
wanted to kill me
um that had no knowledge of who I was or
anything was in Florida this little
black dude named James and at one point
he had strength gotten strangled so he
had no larynx for it basically so
everything was like Hey white boy so he
he would call me over to the cage and
this was our usual routine while he I
was hiding between two pieces of fence
in the Florida Sun couple cells down
from the electric chair
right after the Escape they're taking me
back to Pennsylvania it's so hot I'm
trying to stay out of the sunlight he's
over there doing sit-ups on the ground
do you see what I mean next level I'm
gonna kill dead eyes man the only human
being I ever met that had like those
shark eyes right
same routine he'd go over get his work
and come over he's cut he's like Bruce
Lee
he's already killed seven dudes
and this is in prison [__] okay yeah so
he killed yeah he killed one dude in the
chapel when they let him out the last
time in front of the whole congregation
all right so
he saw me as a trophy I'm 6'2 at that
time I got three body three percent body
fat like I'm ripped you know what I mean
he and he would come over after working
out eagle
foreign you know I get that chance I'm
gonna kill you right and I'll be like I
know James and don't worry homie I get
my shot I'm splattering your face on
that ground he'd be like oh I love it
when you talk like that it makes me so
happy because you are a trophy like he
saw me as the epitome of the next kill
didn't hate me didn't need to hate me he
just wanted to get to me it's spot in
his eyes yeah almost like MMA fighting I
liked him like I like this cat like
I understood him
he wasn't personal I was just that next
year yeah I mean he was straight killer
I like that dude [__] I'd rather deal
with him than the ones that'll sneak up
on your sideways at least you know never
to turn your back on James and if they
would have put us in the same cage he
probably would have gave me the fight of
my life the dude was ripped Beyond rip
sit on a hot
ground and do 250 sit-ups get up and do
one arm push-ups and all that like all
day long waiting for his chance you
mentioned the electric chair now
obviously you were in there for such a
long time
what was it like when a guy you knew
was going to be executed oh there was
two different ones that got executed on
my unit so the first one was Keith
settlemire passive easy going guy killed
his friend
very regretful it broke my heart to see
him marching down the tear and take him
to execute him what were the days
leading up they were feeling like when
you would have conversation he was the
first one in Pennsylvania seeking to be
a volunteer so he was breaking the mold
and everybody was on edge everybody
volunteer yeah he gave up his appeals oh
he just said just when you're sentenced
to die you have power okay you can ask
to be executed right man it starts the
whole process so dudes would come to his
cell like Keith you [__] [__] you're
giving up you're gonna let them kill all
of us that kind of [__] oh because
they're thinking once there's a
precedent they hadn't killed anybody
since 63.
1997 they're about to kill Keith
settlemar one of my good friends so he
wanted out of his uh his time yeah I was
in the cell next to him talking to him
and I knew he was going to do it Brian
and he was so conflicted and I said
that you have to understand that
you have to serve God's will no matter
what happens to you Keith you know
and then they took him out and they
executed him and then the next guy was
the real Buffalo Bill
yeah I got a picture on my phone man
um his name is Gary heidnick and there
was just a recent story it's funny how
we're on here talking but
Gary heidnick abducted six black women
and put them in a pit under his house
and electrocuted one of them and fed
them to the others [__] you used to
speak this mom he was next door to me
man
wow okay so what was it like talking to
someone who'd done that sort of thing
what was the conversation like no no no
no no no
ain't nobody gave a Gary no oxygen man
so this is how it went he kept to
himself because everybody on the unit
basically if they didn't already whoop
his ass didn't have no time for him you
don't do that [__] and get away with
that in prison man
not at that time so
he would get revenge on us whenever the
power went out on this unit there was no
circulating error and it's hush and then
he would put on a crazy performance man
see he used to have a hole cut in the
floor and listen and watch his victims
so this sick bastard would start doing
the performance of these women in Terror
oh my God he up there he gonna kill us
and he would do their voices in falsetto
and then go back to his over uh the
overall voice that he was doing to tell
us how he was God and he was going to
create this [__] race and [__]
dudes would be beaten on their doors
flushing their toilets trying to drown
them out the guards come in and spray
you with pepper spray they want you to
hear his [__]
they're delighton in this bastard
tormenting You by hour after hour
performing this sick ritual of what he
was doing to his women man I still can't
that [__] out of my head if I think
about it
because he was delighting in it God got
his [__] ass back
he asked to be executed guess what
happened
years before he had abducted a mentally
ill black woman
an impregnated her after keeping her
hostage
that child from the rape came out of
nowhere
and she wanted to forgive her daddy
she wanted to love him they brought her
into the death chamber and when he saw
her he [__] broke all that racist
[__] he was spewing about creating a
master race and all that the black man
is weak he ate all that on the spot when
he saw his beautiful biracial daughter
didn't he
so he was a white guy with with with
black women living under the yeah he was
one of those psychologically pretend
Twisters because when he saw his
daughter he broke didn't he right and
they had that in the newspaper so that
was his final moments his final moments
was looking into the face of a child
that he created
what was your I mean obviously your next
thought of this guys uh so you you
obviously
you had a lot of feelings listening to
those voices that he would do what was
your feeling the day he went
man they put chains on this man and
marched them right past my door and he
was geeked
the energy and the smell of his body
came at me and it I actually stood back
man there was something next level about
his
projection of energy man Gary has these
weird big black brown eyes you know what
I mean
he looked like Christ man like on that
kind of figuration but man he was crazy
and when he they came past him I felt
that they eat and he went like this at
me like looking at me I was like [__]
then they marched them off the unit
did you feel any sense of relief or
anything like that or I felt sick to my
stomach to witness that kind of humanity
someone that destroyed themselves with
anger for no reason and made people
horribly suffer I was sick to be around
them look I was around dudes that did
some real
deep dark [__] man
yeah we see the Netflix shows but we
don't have to be around these
[__] yeah I had to live next to
him I had one dude freak out and throw
his chessboard off the table out of his
cell and then try to murder me for three
years because I humiliated him because
he was a genius dude this oh you beat
him in chess oh yeah Jay Schrader so he
was a genius and then I smashed him in
chest not only that but the way I would
do it is like we had to play a board
game that was numbered so 1-64 you have
an identical board as mate
I call out 13 to 29 that's my Pawn in
front of my king two times and you would
throw out 13 to 37 which is the opposite
so our pawns meet in the middle if you
know the number system you can play the
game
so
I would take my Bishop off of 27 or
whatever number and I would yell out my
Bishop bust your queen in the face on
such and such or Checkmate take that
[__] oh my God
this dude went mental and he was the
dude that abducted his partner
killed her and fed her parents her in
ground meatballs man during the search
tended to be looking for
boasting about it
God got him back with stomach cancer
the nurses used to come to his cell
Mr Schrader how you doing today he being
Agony they'd be like
terrible that stomach cancer maybe it
was something you ate wouldn't give him
his medication and [__]
he died in agony they made sure man
you said he he took the girl and turned
her into meatballs and fed up our
parents yeah up in Canada
do you name Jay Schrader man
he thought he was a genius so I did the
one thing that I was doing I was
studying psychology and I did six years
of psychological studies from University
and um well you were able to study well
yeah from Ohio University online so I
did six years of psychology and I wanted
to understand my own developmental
issues by studying it and one of the
things that I was writing to my
instructor about was how in the game of
chess
um people with psychological disorders
were laying bare their problems and you
could see their developmental issues
like a psychopath will continuously try
you know what I mean I had a guy hang on
while I was beating him in a game
only out of fear that I would yell out
something traumatic upon completing the
win
fight like
I wrote this like they will fight to the
last Pawn knowing that they have no
chance to the last move
just not to be humiliated these serial
killers though if there's one thing I I
picked up a little bit of obviously when
you're watching all these documentaries
that we all watch is they always believe
they're the smartest person in the room
yeah it's crazy
um
and then they changed when they hit the
joint you wonder why why because they're
getting beat though
all right look
you go out and you hurt women and
children everybody's got family man
serial killers don't roll in jail
when you have the junior Black Mafia run
in the Pennsylvania prison systems or
you have other gangs run in prison
sickos don't come to jail and light it
up and then leave like a nice trail of
Happiness no they're washing somebody's
socks they're paying protection they're
getting beat down yeah you're not in
control anymore you're not in power yeah
you ain't running your mouth yeah yeah
because they feel powerful obviously
when they do this yeah because they're
doing it to children and weak women or
whoever they feel is weak
that's why look that's why Dahmer got
beat to death in the bathroom he was a
trophy right no it was an example you
can't go out there in a a manner of
hideous attacks upon people
predominantly black and then go to a
black dominated prison and be anything
other than the one that's going to get
it yeah
well you're in prison at the same time
he was in prison yeah
was it talking about you know talking
about him being in there obviously just
another no so he was in a different uh
state for me he was over in Milwaukee
Wisconsin I was thousands of miles away
in Pennsylvania I assume you guys
discussed the case and that it was
probably big news at the time no you
know it's weird because this has become
quite a prominent thing in society you
know the Dharma cases I mean that did
you see the uh Netflix show that they
made about no I don't really get all the
murders and everything yeah I don't
watch things like that I think there's
too much schadenfreude going on with
people delighting and watching this to
the sensation of their feelings for
others really that's an interesting
point think about it man if you're okay
watching all this brutal [__] and
hearing all that horrible screaming
you're losing part of your Humanity in
the exchange and I can I can never watch
shows like that so funny because there's
two people I've had conversations who've
been through real trauma with who've
said that you are one of them and the
other was a girl who was kidnapped um
Elizabeth Smart do you know of her oh
God God bless you yeah so yeah of course
those who don't know Elizabeth Smart was
basically like Madeleine McCann in
America but she was discovered uh she
was forward even when she was kidnapped
nine months later she was discovered
after being rape for a long time yeah
um and it's very well known case in
America right so she can't watch
anything like that now no why should she
want to watch a reality that she lived
like me yeah I don't want to watch
uh prison programming
and I don't I don't like a lot of How
It's overblown or its falsities like
that's why this new program that this
new television series that I'm writing
is going to be about exonerations from a
different aspect that's going to blow
people away the male cells are horrific
by comparison the women treat each other
much nicer all right they [__] about
each other I know the violent levels are
so much less it's about hair pulling men
are trying to out kill each other it's
completely different I'll give you the
difference go to a Men's prison and
you'll see visitors
loads and loads of women keeping the
love alive
go to a women's prison and see how many
men show up
it's horrible that really I never that
never dawned on me I know because I I've
been there all right so what do you
think that is uh it's one of the things
that then determines this aspect in a
women's prison they rebuild family
connections they have daughters and
sisters and mother and father even if
it's not really gay they bond in unison
and they begin tribal repair
you're so right yeah and whereas men
don't have this capacity because
in the tribe it's the center of the
female that keeps the tribe together one
of my best friends in the world uh an
old older woman who's helped me through
the death of my mother
she said to me a woman keeps the family
together
and I honestly have seen
whenever I look at Family Dynamics where
it's chaotic chaotic everyone's falling
out I always look like where's the
mother what's the mother doing here and
if a woman is selfish and she isn't the
The Giver the the the the the the loving
supporting person it will be a mess it's
amazing when you watch those prison
programs how how they do women do us
fall into these roles yeah and gather
around the mother figure and as you've
said rightly these men
it makes you wonder why we are so built
so different like I had a guy a
psychologist on the show who did liking
us and he said like you know at our base
level
you know soldiers in in women or you
know they have the babies you know and
you don't come out in prisons right
Hunter gather
nurturer Giver
when it's not in Balance you're right it
falls apart look
so what's it uh
how many broken homes do we have in this
country
where women are still keeping their [__]
together and those kids are growing up
man
that's amazing all across the world
we've gone through this phenomenon where
the Partnerships are breaking down but
women are still producing generation
after generation a beautiful strong
human beings
I think they're finding it harder you
know in this modern era yeah because you
you you're also
seeing women being inundated with the
need to be equal to Men on on earning
scales and that's a burden on top of
everything else and yeah look
can I ask you a question about when you
got released though yeah your your first
interaction with women post you know
that was a long time I was wondering if
I was gonna be [__] up so this is cool
one of my homegirls from the
neighborhood
came and picked me up like I don't know
a couple weeks after I got out
and she was like Nick
like
I'm gonna throw you some ass just to see
if you're okay
so we're going to go down to South
Philly and get some ice cream and hang
out I'm gonna let you drive my car and
then we're gonna get down so I had sex
in my parents basement while they was
asleep upstairs
and I was kind of like weirded out at
one point it's very natural to be that
way I'm sure well it was strange because
I hadn't been held by anybody for so
long I was
like poof like just to touch me was in
in wow and I bet your senses were
crawling crazy because femininity and
all those smells and feelings and all of
that you know what really drove me crazy
is that
I was being touched
put her hand on my face at one point and
did like this to me and it felt so
amazing
just to have someone touch my face
it was fascinating man isn't it funny
how people would be interested like
immediately expecting you to to think
all of those sexual feelings or whatever
but but when you've been that long
without having that affection yeah it's
it's the little things I went yeah
because I went 15 years without a human
hand touching me from November of 1989
until December of 2003 no one was
allowed to touch me without rubber
gloves on
so so
whatever you feel comfortable sharing
obviously yeah that's good girl but
you know you get to that point where
you're there with her
and all of these feelings are kicking in
can you remember anything else that was
going through your head or how it felt
afterwards when you were just laying
there with her or yeah I started
it's weird like
it wasn't fantastic
it was too much going on
but like the fourth or fifth time
yeah that we hooked up
yeah that that made me feel masculine
again yeah and then and then she was
like okay you know like what do you mean
by masculine again well when you can
really handle your business in a [__]
bedroom do you know what I mean that
full on
she's trying to get out of the bed
because there's just so much going on
and you snatch her by the ankle pull it
back down and work her over for two more
hours
like I I would I had so much thing yeah
yeah I could go for hours man like I
have 20 years plus bro no not only that
what if I opened up an ice cream shop to
you after you dreamed of the taste of
vanilla ice cream for life
you're going to go through all of those
the lights to the nth degree man like I
that must have been hard to get over
that as in like to come to terms with
now I can have it if yeah it's like an
alcoholic taking their first sip of beer
again or whatever after that long like
you are going to naturally over indulge
did you did that happen yeah I was
dating five women at one point
surprise bro damn it wouldn't have
[__] yeah because how was that well it
was hard no because it was hard you know
what it bothered me I started repeating
the same behaviors with everyone so well
you became fake repeating yourself yeah
it's like I wasn't really feeling any
joy and so I stopped you know and then
it just became all about the pleasure
sort of thing of the seeking of it yeah
and I was I was finding out I was only
getting laid because I was more
curiosity than anything so it wasn't me
I was having you know what I mean you
look like and forgive me if I'm wrong
here but you look like you don't you
feel a bit ashamed of this yeah I I why
is that because I'm honestly because I
know I [__] up when I I really just
wanted to have one love affair and I'm
madly in love with Laura Thompson right
now and all my life I wanted to have
that like you're human though yeah and
so we are human and I know but yeah but
I keep getting crucified because I got a
stalker who makes it all known everyone
and tries to make me look dirty so it's
a complex thing where I really wish I
hadn't done things that I've done but
they're done now and I can't do anything
but move forward and the beautiful thing
is
I still like myself I still have the
capacity to go on and be a caring given
person but when you were talking about
that there was a hint of you there that
looked I didn't like that and forgiving
yourself for it yet it isn't forgiving
myself I don't like that I mean I'm just
like every other guy I'm I'm I'm
susceptible to The Wiles of females
right especially after 20 plus years bro
right who could blame you but I don't
want that um well that's not who you are
right now no I'm trying so hard to be
good I swear like I got my head down I I
I kept trying so hard to try and do this
right right
I know I'm flirtatious I know I have an
open like personality and it's easily be
sexually flirtation but I'm not going
anywhere would it man but I I can see
where that's caused me chaos I need to
chill
very hard to deal with I'm sure I mean
if I had done 22 years in prison and all
of a sudden there were women out there
who were like let me try and see what
this guy is like after you know he's in
the news and yada yada I mean you're
you're a human I mean I had an event
down in the uh on the Strand I did a
presentation
um for a woman who was a pen pal with an
artist on death row and she was the
artist so
they're selling these pieces of art for
like 10 grand and everybody's in a black
tie
a very well-known very famous British
billionaire had a woman on his hip walks
up to me he shakes my hand I'm like dude
nice to meet you like Blown Away
I shake her hand she had a note in her
hand with her number on it
like I was I like I kept it cool and I
was like let's put my hand in my pocket
and I was like wow that's some hardcore
Next Level thing
and we often hear about the the death
row uh women romances yeah the women
often send these guys emails letters and
all of that so do you feel like that's
been a factor of what you've gone
through Post Release or even during well
especially post-release so a lot of the
women who are enamored with the guys
that are bad boys and then on deaf
yeah I mean bad boys is one thing yeah
death row in me that's dude they were
fighting in the lobby of the jail to go
visit the Night Stalker dude oh was he
in your prison no he was out in
California remember that guy Richard
Ramirez yeah yeah women were fighting to
get to him because they thought he was
like sexy yeah like oh my God uh see
what I mean yeah so don't beat them yeah
yeah that won't go bad
um yeah I've had different experiences
where
I'm glad that today did you phone that
woman no I was so horrified that she had
done that too man
oh that was not he wasn't yeah yeah yo
man that's cold yeah
but it's a nice story to tell she wants
that death she was man she was fine too
so yeah
it's crazy I I know all right so I and I
ain't gonna lie man I got a [__] gift
like I can light it up
oh
yeah all right well think about it I
dreamed about making love to someone so
long when I got a chance all those
dreams were infinitely helpful
I mean I used to sit my soul and
daydream so beautifully
that I would meet her in a cafe in Paris
and we would share a laugh and as we
walked along the shanzi a
I would hold her hand and knowing that
there was this warm embrace we were
going to somehow make love I would
Daydream out all that whole beautiful
sequence so then in my personal life
that's what I was doing man I was trying
to be that super romantic love
was it ever difficult to achieve that
not with Laura man imagine me and her
had some of the most beautiful romantic
times in my life man
we stood before a beautiful tree in
Geneva and we set our vows to each other
about love we said we didn't need no
preacher to talk about what love meant
to us
like I remember
a lot of times there was always a ritual
no matter what trip I was on when I came
home that girl was going to wear my
shirt
it was part of it for her that romantic
thing of wearing me to bed with me you
know or waking up she always had to have
my shirts on
so that was a nice feel in our how have
you survived without that connection
then in America for those years like it
was it three years you were more so two
years yes it's been really difficult
that's why I
with this brain injury I'm really
praying that love is a solution for me
and I need someone to wake up and help
me Brian
I do very difficult on my own and I knew
it was getting to be too much so you're
a month we're all [__] on our own I'm
useless yeah you know we all need a
woman nothing can make you happier than
a good woman nothing can make you feel
more
um Awake and Alive than someone who
listens to you because when you wake up
and you have no one to speak to it
becomes an empty thing yeah
well I'm glad you're over here mate and
I'm glad that you've had this like this
new beginning again you know this new
experience with all these creators and
you're going to do the TV show and
you're talking to Laura again and I I
know it's been hard I've been watching
from a farm we've been talking here and
there and it I was worried about you
especially when I seen you were living
in the woods I was like [__] but now
sitting here in the flesh you know you
got your suit on You're motivated got a
new job bro got a new seat I'm delighted
for you man and literally I know
everyone's going to be hoping for the
best for you and uh let's do this again
I'm so glad that I came here to London
because I have always felt like a bad
[__] walking around in a suit
but today was like next level [__] oh
man you look the bollocks no because I'm
coming to see my boy you understand yeah
when you're on a mission man I I rocked
this today okay well we'll get some food
and uh we're gonna we're gonna wrap it
here but thanks to everyone who watched
and thank you to Nick for coming in
don't forget to like the video Stay
subscribed to the true Jordan YouTube
channel thanks very much
cheers brother cheers that was [__]
awesome